[Music]
Joe have you heard about these three
Russian doctors who have mysteriously
falling out of windows what two weeks
well Russian windows are really big sure
windows are big didn't have heard that
Russian professionals tend to fall out
of windows a lot mmm
because of the mob there yeah yeah I
heard that people get killed very
frequently and the police are always
like it's another window accident oh he
fell to window and shot himself in the
head they need to fix this [ __ ] yeah
these dang windows you start boarding of
every window yeah okay we need to bag
windows
why don't they close them yeah her like
like in companies like you know there
might be a bunch of business executives
and if they have a power struggle like
it goes into assassinations and I heard
it's pretty pretty gangster over there
that's kind of it seems to be happening
right now with these doctors because I
didn't like my new veneers [ __ ] you know
it's it's around coronavirus stuff so
not the dentist two of the doctors they
that have been into Erlich okay so there
there have been three that fell out of
windows right two of them have died one
of them is in intensive care right now
oh can you tell us the details that was
about the font of the hospital they only
have one [ __ ] assassination move huh
any other move it's just throw about the
window well that doctor that is right
now in intensive care
so him and this other doctor they had
posted a video or I think there
paramedics and they had posted a video
them saying like you know these working
conditions are insane we haven't been
able we haven't been released from our
ship we're tired we don't have enough
PPE and the other doctor not the one I
got pushed out the window with the other
one he was they were saying that he had
just been oh [ __ ] am I getting confused
now one of the two doctors got tested
positive or coronavirus and he was
saying like they're still making me work
like this isn't right that's happening
here too right so then then days later a
second video was released and that's
when he was backing off of the comments
and saying like I I had been actually I
had too much vodka I don't have Corona
just joking you know take it back yeah
he said that he had been emotional and
that his boss did eventually tell him to
stop working and then he fell out of a
window is when he was admitted to the
hospital he fell out of the window why
are there so many clumsy Russian doctors
it was from the second-floor window Pam
but previous to this incident because
he's the most recent one previous to
that there were two other doctors female
doctors where they were protesting their
working conditions or not one of them
was protesting the working conditions
and the other one she was being blamed
after her colleagues contracted the
virus and they were they were blaming
her for not having enough like
procedures in place to protect the proof
so the reason why they're dying is
because they're complaining too much and
they're getting assassinated by the
owners of the hospital well yeah cuz one
of the girls she had just been on a
phone call with some like health health
care people and shortly after is when
she fell out the five the fifth story
window and then to use healthcare
professional people they were like I
don't know what call you're talking
about we weren't on the call Wow
I mean is it the hospital or is it the
government right it seems like it might
be the government cuz I like glaciers
run by the government huh are the
hospital's run by the government over
there oh I don't know I don't know how
their health care system works I assume
so communists yeah they're a state-run
you guys watch it correct right like so
even the whole sporting and everything
is ran by the government like steroids
to seeing like what I thought they're
not communist anymore I think that was
before the Soviet yeah what are they can
get her up oh yeah but they're not
dictatorship kind it's a fake democracy
because Putin keeps winning so it's
almost like communist then I guess they
because the Soviet Union was communist
and now they're supposed to be whatever
but I heard it's a gangster country like
it's just ran by like the mob there I
thought that's how America is because it
was the other doctor that Asian one I
think in America that was like oh I'm
finding out like how to actually attack
the virus and we talked about that
supposed to the Sassa nation yeah he got
shot like five times
okay so there's a researcher that asian
guy right yeah yeah he's a he's a he's a
researcher and he was close to a cure
and so him he was found shot dead in his
car I believe in his partner another
researcher was found several miles away
dead as well and shot anything fall out
of windows no America different yeah
wait may never caught who I don't really
read into it was like it's because in
everyone so they're like a week before
they were like all the they're making
breakthroughs with finding out how to
like defeat the virus and everyone was
like oh protect his view before they get
killed
and they get killed and then obviously
the other company that's like funded by
the government's like multi multi
multi-billion dollar company now that
they just came out and was like oh
they're finding the they're doing good
research on it so their stock prices are
going up so I'm sure people in the
government's making all the money off of
it so it's like it always adds up in a
weird way we're like their actual
interest in like where their money lies
the
rather the virus keep going and kill the
people that are actually doing good work
- you know they're clearly assassinating
people right in front of our eyes and
nobody gives a [ __ ] that's not well it's
also not exactly the kind of news we're
going we should speak up more about this
guys yeah I think people that are about
to find a cure needs to stop [ __ ]
releasing that [ __ ] before they find a
cure or make a video that will go public
unless you keep changing the scheduled
date yeah see people don't fear for
their lives enough all right that's
that's the problem but they can also
just take it down like that if they find
it because these innocent people are
probably thinking hey guys let's do
something great and solve the world of
[ __ ] Cove in nineteen so they worked
their asses off day and night not even
[ __ ] spending time to jack off and
the two researchers are just [ __ ]
getting it on and then they're like
alright man we almost got a cure let's
let the news know or whatever and
everyone's like yay they're on the
[ __ ] cure and they're like we're
gonna do this for free everyone's gonna
be happy not knowing that you might die
your [ __ ] nonprofit son of a [ __ ]
there's so many good people that are
inventors and all this stuff scientists
and they come out with [ __ ] and there
are like groups out there in the oil
industry car industry like they're just
constantly scrubbing for patents and
inventions and things that are coming
out and I heard from the underground
from a close family member of mine of
someone that developed it was a client
of his he developed a mortar that can go
like 500 miles on like a gallon of gas
or some insane [ __ ] right now we have
electric cars but this was back in a
late night motor like a more like an
engine
so it was it was it was something at the
time that was ground [ __ ] breaking
right so he was proposition and
approached as soon as he put in the pens
to get this off his hands for a lot of
money you didn't take it you there's no
this is gonna change the world and I'm
gonna be the patent owner so then when
this technology rolls out you know I'm
gonna have a piece of all that just like
the boys who invented the blinkers right
there making mad money and then all of a
sudden he called and he says this ain't
gonna go down can't really talk about it
see ya disappeared off of the face of
the [ __ ] earth and do we have a car
that can go 500 miles on a gallon I
don't know do we today I don't know but
but but moral the story is [ __ ] like
that really goes down in this world so
we would be a lot but if it wasn't for
greed yes
but greed you actual in our human DNA's
that's what we're the underdeveloped
species like compared to aliens that
supposedly are out there compared to
animals too because you don't see
[ __ ] other animals like stocking up
more than they really need Thomas Edison
[ __ ] race in anal sex
hardcore what Thomas Edison [ __ ]
everybody up there was like oh mr.
electric he [ __ ] everybody up because
mister tell Tesla and that's why Elon
Musk is a [ __ ] boss he was
developing electric conductor charger
thingy a free energy because he wasn't a
greedy businessman like Thomas Edison
mr. Tesla was like this [ __ ] is gonna
help human beings get into the next
level and he developed these towers
where he could charge and use free
electricity and all this [ __ ] and mr.
Edison was like [ __ ] that everybody
should be playing paying an electric
bill like why you're gonna die you're
probably like a [ __ ] ton of money
already but me for the legacy and like
that like to take care of generations on
well for the time being you don't think
you're gonna die when you're in the
moment right right
gonna die haha now I don't believe after
like if I'm gonna die though have
technology Tom maybe buy and look for 50
years
yeah make it fifty years later think
about it like let's say your family
owned a monopoly on carpets you're gonna
let other people [ __ ] sell carpets on
your block hell naw man somebody try to
open up a store that's gonna change the
whole carpet industry and just for
people that's even trying to turn it
into like wood floors [ __ ] that dude
your family's gonna do whatever can to
keep the carpets alive we would marry
into the family and it will become one
will offer the carbon and wood yeah did
busted ass ladies man bad game that's a
game of thrones move dude Wow
flooring company merger together the
flooring family the flooring the
flooring floor infested our flooring
family's mortars and flooring
[Music]